So pins provides a way
to easily share things
either across projects,
or across people.
What ends up happening
oftentimes in data science
work, we have some asset.
And maybe it's data,
or it's a model.
Or it's some other R object.
And we either need to reuse
this asset later on downstream
or across different
projects, or we
might need to share it with
different members of our team.
We say anything that can
be serializable in R.
So think about how you
might stick something
on a cork board, so
you can keep it handy.
Or you stick a flyer on a
community bulletin board
at the grocery store, so
that other people can see it.
And so, the pins
package pins objects
to what's called a board.
This is analogous to
this corkboard idea.
And so, this board is this
place where files are written,
and they're read from.
Examples of boards
are things like, you
can have a board
that's S3 storage,
shared folders like
network drives or Dropbox.
You can have your RCO
connect be a board,
a SharePoint site be board.
Really, it's just a
filestore, a file share.
Nothing magical about that.
It's just pins has a
nomenclature and a way
of organizing things in
this place on the board,
so that you can interact with
them through the package.
So what I'm hearing is, I
can pin all kinds of things
in all kinds of locations?
Yes it works
nicely with Connect,
but there's nothing
specifically implemented
in pins for Connect.
The things that Connect
does to make life
for pins a little bit better,
Connect will give you access
to the same sharing--
content sharing
settings that you
have for any piece of
content on Connect.
So I can put my pin
on Connect, and I
can specify who should be able
to access it and share it.
And then, pins does have a nice
preview of the pinned object.
I like that feature, but
that's a Connect implementation
for how it reads pins.
Nothing specific in the
pins package itself.
So if I work by
myself, either in--
for whatever reason,
I am a team of one.
How might I use pins?
A lot comes down to
what are your pain points?
And what do you have
available to you already
for storing data, sharing data,
accessing data downstream,
things like that?
In your team of one, do
you need to reuse something
in other work?
Do you have a reference table or
some kind of other information
that multiple projects
are going to use?
You might need to
come back to this.
Pins could be a pretty
good use case for that.
Or do you just not have a
convenient place to put things?
Pins comes in and gets
to be really helpful
when you just maybe don't have
another place to store data.
Sometimes, teams that don't
have ready access to a database,
find pins to be pretty
helpful because it
makes them self-sufficient.
It can be more
autonomous in this way.
You don't have the
mechanism to either get
a hold of a database,
or have one set up.
Or even the data that
you're working with isn't--
what's the right word?
--worthy of being
in the database.
Then you can use a
pin as a place to I'm
going to have this
nice location where
it's organized, its versioned.
I can work through cached
versions of it as well,
so things go faster.
And it helps to alleviate
other pain points.
If you have places
like if putting things
in Dropbox, or on GitHub.
If those things are
working for you already,
then you don't need to bring
this tool into your toolbox
per se.
What pain points do you have?
And what needs do you
maybe have in terms
of being able to track versions
or share things more readily?
That was one of my entry
points for pins, too,
is working with Excel
files just like that.
And what do you do when
you've got this Excel
file in your workflow?
At some point, you're going
to get another version of it.
And either on the file server,
where the file's stored,
or in your code, every
time there's a new version,
you're going to go in
there and rename it.
And so, the final version one,
or latest copy, or whatever.
Final final.
With your initials on the end.
And so, somewhere
along the line,
you're going to be putting
some kind of hacked versioning
nomenclature on it.
And there's this introducing
possibility for error,
of course.
How many times
have you gone out,
and you've run your
whole analysis?
And you realize, oh, I forgot
to change the read underscore
CSV to the latest version?
Or do you actually have more
rigor going to the file server
and changing the file name,
so that the latest version
is always called whatever?
Data dot CSV, and then
everything else is archived?
In some form or fashion, you're
implementing this hacky way
of keeping things current.
Whereas with pins, you
can pin that CSV and--
so pins has different
options for versioning,
but, fundamentally, you
can have pins always
pull the latest version.
And so, whenever your code
just says pin read data
from my pin board,
it's always going
to pull the latest version.
Or if you want to get
specific, you can say,
I want this particular version
always niche every time.
So that even if new
versions come online,
then you're always
referencing the specific one.
Let's say I'm using Dropbox.
Do I just get one board?
Or can I set up different
boards for different projects?
Or is it like one
board per system?
Like I get one Dropbox board,
one Google Drive board,
one Connect board?
Yeah.
It took me a while to
get my mind around what's
this thing called a board.
It sounds like there's magic
under the hood or something
really special about boards.
There's nothing really super
exciting about boards, per se.
It's a file path basically.
It's a file path.
So I have on my screen here--
this is my browser window here.
I started a Dropbox location.
I have a folder called pins.
I manually created this
folder called pins,
and so, earlier today, I
just started pinning stuff.
But this is all
that my board is.
My board is a file path.
That's users Katie,
Dropbox, pins.
And this is where
I've defined it.
This is my board.
And what happens when
you define a board,
it just says, this is where
I'm going to go write or read
my files, and where they live.
And while we're here, what do
these magical, mythical pins
look like on the file path?
It's not that special.
So it's a hash of the
date, and the time,
and a particular hash
for the pin itself
and two things inside.
Here's an RDS file with
my classic penguins data,
and here's a text file.
It's just got metadata
included in it.
So if I wanted to, I could
go and just go into my code,
and read that RDS file manually.
It's not once a
pin, always a pin.
It's just a thing.
It's just a
serializable thing in R.
But pins is going
to make it easier
for me to find these
locations, work
with them in a
consistent manner,
pull them in, read them
in, and interpret and work
with this metadata overall.
One of the first
things that you do
with pins is define your
board, and like I said,
your board can be on Connect.
It can be on S3.
It can be GitHub, or a folder
URL local, or whatever.
So in this case,
just I like being
able to see what we're
doing while we're playing.
So I'm creating this board.
There's just a folder.
This folder happens to
be my Dropbox pack here.
But I can, to my
heart's content,
let's make another board
and make it versioned.
We'll talk about
that in a second.
Board folder.
Gosh, I have to type on this?
You know the autocomplete?
Dropbox.
This is fabulous.
So I've created two different
definitions for my board.
This one's versioned.
Sorry.
This one is not versioned.
This one is versioned.
It's the same file path.
I can have multiple boards.
I'm just describing.
With each definition
of board, I'm
just describing
where it is, how I'm
accessing it, and different
characteristics of it.
So, for example, these two
different boards, regular board
and board versioned.
I'm just saying, when I'm
using this file path, when
I'm using this board, either
do or don't automatically
keep multiple versions
of my pin for me.
And so, there's different ways
for dealing with versions.
You can define things at this
higher level on the board
level.
It says, anything that
I pin to this board,
I want it automatically
to be versioned.
And, for example, if you're
doing an RStudio Connect board,
by default, the RS
Connect board itself
is versioned [INAUDIBLE] true.
Just out of the box default.
But typically, the
versioning is false,
is turned off by default. And
if so, then you can also then do
versioning at the pin level.
And so, you can see down
here as I've defined my pin--
We're getting
ahead of ourselves.
Defined my pin.
I can specify, even if
my board isn't versioned,
I can make my
specific pin versioned
and then have different
iterations of it.
That's really cool.
Caching is another nice
feature that, once you pull--
once you get it set up,
you've pulled in your pin.
There will be a cached
version of that.
And so, it will only
pull a fresh version
if the data has
changed, and so, it
can be a time saver
utilizing that cache overall.
Are there some limits?
Can I just pin everything?
No.
That would be irresponsible.
You need to think a little
bit about what's appropriate,
so there's two elements.
What's appropriate in terms
of what are you trying to pin?
Is it something that maybe
belongs in a database?
Don't use pins for long-term
archival storage of data.
Things like your
crown jewel data.
Don't make that a pin.
That needs to go in a database.
There are best practices
around data, and databases,
and backing things up, and
access all of these things.
Don't replace your
databases with pins.
A good practice is to
make dependable objects
something that is reproducible.
Don't count on your pin
being your source of truth
for all of eternity.
Make sure it's something
that you can programmatically
reproduce.
Pins are often really
good with ephemeral data.
Stuff that's just
like coming in.
They're in the
middle of my process.
I need to stick this
somewhere and then be done--
keep working with it.
Ephemeral data's really good,
really lightweight data.
Lookup tables, stuff like that.
Things that make
your life easier
is good to use for a pin.
And then in terms of size, a
few hundred megabytes is great.
If it's too big for Excel,
it's too big to pin.
Don't push it.
So we talked about
boards already.
Boards, it's not magic.
Think of it just as a file path.
Where am I going?
And so, in this case, let's
just use this board here.
That is my Dropbox location.
Get rid of this one here.
If I'm on the board--
So first of all, I can
just do a quick query.
What's out there?
So I'm going to
do board, and pins
is pipeable, which is nice.
So you can work with it.
I'll typically define my
board as my first step,
and then pipe that into all
of my different functions.
So we'll pipe board
into pin list,
and you can see here's all
of my pins that I have,
and this is mimicking.
It's bringing in what you can
see here in my file browser.
There's also if you're not
quite sure what's out there
or if you want to
get more information,
pin_search is nice.
pin_search will search the names
and the titles of your pens.
So in this instance, I
don't have very many pins,
so I'm just going to
search for the blank query,
the double quotation marks.
It does present in a nicer
format than just the list
that we got in the last one.
You can see a little
bit more information
be created in the
file size and whatnot.
And like I said, it will
search the name in the title.
So if I'm looking for
penguins, I've got two pins.
I've got penguins, and
I have not penguins,
so searching those
different things.
But this is good
for finding things.
So pins has metadata
associated with them,
which can be pretty helpful.
So I've got this pin here.
It's not super exciting,
but it's just a timestamp.
But the metadata associated
with that, I can see what it is.
And in this case,
when I pinned it,
you can also include
your own custom metadata.
So that can be very useful.
As you're building
out a project or you
want to put specific
things into that metadata,
there is a place to put
that into the metadata.
You can see how I put that in
up here as I wrote this pin,
and I just specified
the metadata as a list.
I love that.
And then different versions--
we've talked about versions.
So I can see what
versions I have.
So here are I pin
versions for timestamps.
I've got five
different versions,
and let's just see for sanity.
Over here in my
actual file browser,
here are my five
different versions.
And you can see, it does
get to be duplicative.
It's just copy, copy,
copy, one after another.
So it's not the smartest
package in terms of file space.
This is going back to this.
Use pins if it makes
your life easier.
It's quick and
dirty, and it's there
to help you to get things done.
Are there more elegant
ways of doing things?
Sure.
Are there maybe better workflows
for long-term archival data
storage?
Absolutely, but
pins are definitely
useful in these use cases.
So we've talked
about the pin_read
and its complement,
the pin_write
and the pin_read functions.
There is another set of
functions for pin_upload
and pin_download.
And so these take a little
bit of an abstraction layer
further out.
And really, this is for being
able to pin any kind of file,
like an RData file, for example.
So if you have an RData file--
again, here's my board,
my Dropbox board.
I have this RData file.
And what is it?
Right, it's just this collection
of my four different variables
and things that I
had for breakfast.
So if I wanted to
put this on a board,
I'd use the pin_upload function.
And pin_upload,
we can see what's
going to happen over here.
I have this over here.
And this is looking familiar.
Here's my hash, but here's
my RData file itself.
No magic there.
Here's my metadata, and it's
just tightly nested over here
in my file folder.
And you'll note here,
it's replaced the version
that I had before as
opposed to appending
a version because I didn't tell
it I want a version for it.
And so the complement to
pin_upload is pin_download.
And what pin_download
does is it returns a path
to the cached file
that it's downloaded.
So what does that look like?
Here's my output.
Here's where it's living.
Here's where it's downloaded
that file and cached it.
And so I can now--
if I want to bring that
object in, pins board,
packed a cache pile,
I have my pack.
And let's just load it.
So you can use pin_upload
and pin_download to be
able to bring other objects,
files, things like that
into that structure
that pins provides
for being able to read
metadata, play with versions,
called things, have
caching, things like that.
It's one of the legacy
functions in the API.
And so what that means, so the
first iteration, I would say,
of the pins package had a
different overall format
and different API behind
it for doing the read
and write functions.
And so in-- gosh, maybe nine
months ago, maybe a year ago,
I don't know.
It depends on the time.
It doesn't make sense anymore.
A little while
ago, a new version,
a new API version
of pins came out,
and it started pins version 1.0.
We're at 1.01 right
now, I believe.
And that retooled
under the hood the API
that was calling, and
writing, and interacting
with pin boards.
And we also saw some of the
older functions drop off.
That being said
though, that doesn't
mean-- so Google Cloud doesn't
mean that that's not going
to be a board in the future.
There's currently
an issue right now
on the repo to bring
Google Cloud as one
of the new
implementations of boards,
and really, it's just
a matter of if that's
something that's
useful for folks,
we just need people to go in
and put a plus 1 on the issue
to help weigh the priority
for developing that.
So we've talked about pinning
data, pinning data frames,
things like that.
But pinning models is
a really nice workflow.
And all the work that
Julia's been doing around
vetiver I think showcases
that really nicely.
And so what you can do with
the package, with vetiver,
you can pin a vetiver model.
And then with that, you'll
have all the information
about that model that you
need to deploy it, and call
it, and work with it.
And so you can then
call that model
or different versions
of that model
into other assets downstream.
So a super simple example
of that, so earlier today--
let's see what I have.
I borrowed some of
Julia's nice work here--
a model that she has
just demonstrated here
with home prices in Sacramento.
She's using a random forest
model, and creating this model,
saving it as a vetiver model.
And if we do this
right-- let's actually
look at this, what
this looks like.
So what is v?
B is a ranger regression
modeling workflow
using core features.
So with this, I'm
going to pin this.
In this case again, I'm
going to just pin it
on my Dropbox folder.
So we'll pin this.
And where's my notebook?
So I have these
different models here.
And now I'm going
to use this model.
So first of all, one
of these workflows
that she's illustrated is to
wrap this model up into an API
so that you can pin
it and query it.
So I'll take this model, and
my background job here, there's
functions within
the vetiver package
for creating a vetiver API.
In this case, I'm just
going to run this locally.
I could publish my API.
I could publish it
somewhere hosted on Connect
or host it in some
other place that I
have in my infrastructure.
Right now I'm just going
to run this locally
so I can think off of this.
And what this looks
like, so if you run this,
this is just running locally.
It has a nice swagger
interface so I can
test it out and try my model.
So first, I'm going
to just do it.
This is just a ping,
and it's just responding
with the time of the day.
But if I want to
run this locally--
so I'm actually going to run
this as a background job,
because when this is running--
let me run this again.
If this is running, it's
just consuming and occupying
my console, so I can't
interact with it.
A whole lot of good, that does.
I've got to run this
as a background job
so that I can interact and
still play with my console.
So here's my background job,
and I'm going to run this.
And this is now running.
So I just go to a browser.
Let's pull up a browser window.
So here I'm at a
browser window, just
like we had at the preview, but
now I have a console window.
And so I'm going to use my
model that's been pinned,
and I'm going to
define an endpoint.
My endpoint is this
prediction endpoint here.
And I'm going to
create some new data
and then predict
off that endpoint.
And so I just run predictions
off of that pin model
that I have hosted--
that I have running
[INAUDIBLE] in the background.
But what's nice is that in
this model that I'm running,
I remember I pulled it from
a pin I've got that in a pin.
I specified the version.
So say I had a different
version of this model
that I wanted to
run, well, let's see.
Which versions do I have?
I've got three different
versions right here.
I want to instead
grab this version.
All right, if I wanted
to use this version,
then I would just change
here which particular version
that I'd be reading
in from my pen
and serving up VMI API overall.
And so this is a nice way that
you can toggle back and forth
and try different versions
of your pinned model.